الهزات الارتداديه التي تضرب هاتاي مستمره
منذ الصباح وشعرنا بها يعني تقريبا كل نصف
ساعه الى 40 دقيقه هناك هزه ارتداديه كنت
يعني صعدت الى جسر مشاه للتصوير مشهد شعرت
بها جدا هذه الهزه الارتداديه نحن لا نزال
في وسط المدينه وهذا المبنى الذي يظهر
امامك على الشاشه له قصه بانه اليوم تم
اخراج 10 اشخاص منه احدهم كان على قيد
الحياه
ولا تزال عائلات باكملها محاصره تحت هذا
المبنى من ضمنها عائله مغربيه لم تخرج حتى
هذه اللحظه وهم الان يعني يسابقون الزمن
لانهم بما انه خرج شخص على قيد الحياه
كانوا منذ قليل ايضا طلبوا منا ان نخفض
الاصوات لانهم على ما يبدو استمعوا الى
اصوات ناس
شهدناهم يخرجون اغراض وحاجيات لاسر على ما
تشبه كانت غرفه نوم اطفال اخرجوا منها
اكياس وامور اخرى هذا المشهد خالد في
هاتاي يتكرر اليوم اعداد المنقذين والفرق
لانقاذ تتزايد بشكل كبير جدا وهنالك
تعزيزات كبيره لانه حجم الدمار لا يزال
هائل جدا هذه البنايه تحديدا الان جل
الاهتمام يتركز عليها لانه لانها لم يعني
لم يكن العمل قد بدا بها وبالتالي هنالك
عائلات ومن المؤكد ان هنالك عائلات لا
تزال محتجزه تحت هذه الانقاض وكما قلت لك
من ضمنها عائله مغربيه المفيد جدا والمهم
جدا والذي يبعث الى الامل انهم استخرجوا
اليوم من هذه البنايه على قيد الحياه وهذا
مهم خالد يجعلنا نعود الى سؤال الزمن
والوقت والايام وكم يستطيع الانسان ان
يمكث ويقاوم تحت الانقاض هذا شيء مهم
وسعيد جدا وبالتالي هنالك امكانيه لانهم
منذ قليل كما قلت لك سمعوا اصوات اشخاص
تحت الانقاض او اشارات معينه وطلبوا من
الجميع ان يخفض صوته كما